well kevin first of all congratulations
the number one show on television when
did you know the magnitude of what
yellowstone has become was there a
moment for you where you realized wow
you know i have people come up to me a
lot and one of the
most satisfying things to me is that
when they maybe talk about a favorite
thing
they don't always land on the same thing
i i feel like i really not like my
career so much if it was always one
thing one thing and so sometimes it
ranges between you know 10 movies i
don't know what's going to come out of
somebody's mouth so that's always been
really satisfying but this show has
really hit a nerve with a lot of people
it's something to go to i don't measure
at all against the things i've done i've
only been in television twice once was
hatfield and mccoy's and that had a
tremendous reception and this has had
the same thing but this has had a
growing thing it's you know i think a
lot of people want to say what beth gets
to say a lot of people want to get to do
what rip gets to do and i think a lot of
people wish they could say some of the
things i say when it seems like there's
a lot on the line it's like sometimes
the things i get to say come out really
they're kind of smart things taylor's
written some smart dialogue to it you
know and usually greatest majority of us
when we get confronted with issues like
that we're driving home why didn't i say
that when it was at its most critical
but in yellowstone a lot of times we're
we're saying the thing that i think a
lot of people would like to say
you're good man casey
sometimes good men have to do real bad
things you mentioned tremendous
reception we loved seeing the cast at
the sag awards and receiving that
overdue love now there's a lot of emmys
buzz surrounding the show what would
that recognition mean to you you know
we've been doing the same work from the
first season and i think that that's
that's number one been really important
to me recognition comes just keep doing
the riding has to stay strong keep doing
what we're doing
and then
people catch up to in your life because
you can do a lot of things to get
noticed or whatever but if you're kind
of trying to be relevant in your own
life it means you have to be doing the
things that you feel like are important
to you if the world gets in sync with
what you like how great is that but if
you're always chasing an idea that's
already working and trying to throw a
spin on it there's a business to that
and that's done all the time and there's
nothing really really wrong with it but
it's not the way i can conduct myself
you know when i found yellowstone it
hadn't been made i liked the story i
thought we could do this so the idea
that it's good that doesn't surprise me
at all the idea that it blew up that's
something you can't always predict now
here we are heading into season five
each season we're introduced to someone
who wants to take the duttons down who
is that someone this season the issues
in america have always been kind of
overland
you know
from the moment people started moving
across this continent it was who who was
who could get it who was tough enough to
hold on to it this thing orchestrates
itself around that idea this is a five
generation family that's not a made-up
thing that happens harvesting cattle
that's not made up that work is being
done every day in america but the issues
of the land what's going to happen when
this guy passes or is children going to
want this is are the laws that are in
place right now going to divide up the
rants because they can't pay the taxes
you know and then there's
environmentalists that have issues with
somebody who seems to have so much
there's people who want to make profit
on the land who want to build airports
and really beautiful places you know for
all the fun the language is for all the
exciting moments that you know kind of
we know
really stretch the boundaries because
most of us would be in jail but by this
time they would figure out that i had
killed people there is an element of
that's something that's very current and
that is is the pressure
of of of land how people come after it
whether it be environmentalists whether
it be politicians whether it be people
that you know just think that somebody
just has too much and then the reality
of what happens when you want to pass
something that's been in your life your
whole life and you realize that your
children won't be able to afford to pay
the taxes inheritance and what you've
had is going to break into a thousand
pieces so the duttons are fighting for
the land once again they are in a much
different way which is frustrating for
john dutton i think his father his
grandfather's great grandfather those
people they were able to walk across a
fence and really butt heads with
somebody they didn't need a lawyer to do
it they didn't need an agent or a
publicity person or they did it
themselves i think john is frustrated
because he's cut from that same cloth
but when he makes those moves those can
become problems for him and politics is
about to overrun him where have you been
keeping my promise which promise is this
the one where i swore to destroy
anything that hurts you how is beth and
john teaming up this season she's a one
of a kind and
and she's impossible to control but her
loyalty is so strong for her father that
even in her wildest moments she can
think clearly so she comes at things
from a different angle than john and
john at his core if you boil him down
he is a rancher now heading into season
five she is a married woman will that
soften her at all no she's still a
tornado no no
you know i mean he even admits that
that's the
part that he maybe even envies is that
she's so wild and so free it's
frustrating it's sometimes embarrassing
it's trouble but on the other hand you
know he envies that kind of freedom you
know maybe she will
lose a wild streak but she just doesn't
seem to what do you think it is about
the relationship between john and beth
that makes it one of the most unique
father-daughter relationships that we've
seen on tv she has a guilt about
something that was also the love of his
life his wife
but he's never
laid that on her in any way it's also
she's my daughter and there's mystical
bonds between
you know you can have children and and
they can love you
but they're not you know the bonds that
that they share and you know there comes
a moment where you raise a child and
you're you're tying their shoes and
you're getting them in the car and
you're doing everything
and then their first moment they try to
explain to you how a computer works you
realize oh they're teaching me something
you know beth is at this point where if
she can concentrate long enough about
what the problem is she can usually come
up with a song we're also in this very
interesting situation heading into
season five where essentially john and
beth have blackmail over jamie now and
kind of own him right what would you
want to see happen with jamie could you
see him falling in good graces with john
again probably the show would end
you know there'd be nothing to play
against you know i don't like drama in
my own life personally i don't like it
you know some people seem to thrive on
drama i don't really like it so my
dysfunctional family really disturbs me
i can walk away from it we're not always
privy to where the story's going quite
honestly
do it all right i'll start making calls
you know taylor has actually told me
that he knows how yellowstone ends do
you know no i don't know how to end
would you want to know yeah kaido you
want to know yeah
i'm going to end it if it doesn't end
how long do you
i don't know but i'll go till i'm not
interested i'll go till it it doesn't
feel like um
we're interesting and right now we have
our foot on the gas and that feels okay
to me
uh i have i have interests that are
outside of you know everything i do
including the movies so i i have other
things that i will
want to do what is next for you
well i i don't know i i just feel like
you know i you know i listen when i was
younger i grew up in such a conservative
way you know i actually thought the
world was flat you know i mean i didn't
know what was possible for me
the way i you know you know i came up
with that really good foundation but i
didn't
you know i thought
there was a lot that i needed to learn
there's a lot that i still need to learn
you know what will i regret when i do
leave you know
shuffle off you know it's probably the
books i'll never have read and the songs
i'll never heard the stories you know
there's stuff left
[Music]